i'd like to ask you about solzhenitsyn
and our individual role as ants in this
very large society so he says that uh
some version of the line between good
and evil runs to the heart of every man
do you think all of us are capable of
good and evil like
what's our role in this play
uh in this game we're all playing
is all of us capable to play any role
like is there an ultimate responsibility
to um
you mentioned maintaining innocence or
whatever the
whatever the highest ideal for a society
you want
are all of us capable of living up to
that and that's our responsibility
or
or is there significant limitations to
what we're able to do in terms of good
and evil
so there is a certain way if you are not
terrible if you are committed to some
kind of civilizational agency
a next level agent that you are serving
some kind of transcendent principle
in the eyes of that transcendental
principle you are able to discern good
from evil otherwise you cannot otherwise
you have just individual aesthetics
right the cat that is torturing a mouse
is not evil because the cat does not
envision or no part of the world
of the cat is envisioning a world where
there is no violence and nobody is
suffering yeah right if you have an
aesthetic where you want to protect
innocence then torturing uh somebody
needlessly is evil
but only then
no but within i guess the question is
within the aesthetic like within
your
sense of what is good and evil are we
still
it seems like
we're still able to uh commit evil
yes so basically if you are committing
to this next level agent you are not
necessarily are this next level agent
right you are part of it you have a
relationship to it like a cell does to
its organism it's hyper organism and it
only exists to the degree that it's
being implemented by you and others
and
that means that you're not completely
fully serving it you have freedom in
what you decide whether you are acting
on your impulses and local incentives on
your feral impulses so to speak or
whether you're committing to it and what
you perceive then is a tension between
what you would be doing with respect to
the thing that you
recognize as the sacred if you do
and what you're actually doing and this
is the line between good and evil right
where you see oh i'm here acting on my
local incentives or impulses and here
i'm acting on what i consider to be
sacred and there's a tension between
those and this is the line between good
and evil that might run through your
heart
and if you don't have that if you don't
have this relationship to a
transcendental agent you could call this
relationship to the next level agent
soul right it's not a thing it's not an
immortal thing that is intrinsically
valuable it's a certain kind of
relationship that you project to
understand what's happening somebody is
serving this transcendental sacredness
or they're not
if you don't have your soul you cannot
be evil you're just a complex
natural phenomenon
you